simplifica la expresión racional e
indica el dominio muy bien vamos a
empezar con esto del dominio el dominio
es simplemente que valores puede tomar x
es decir si pensamos a esto como una
función digamos f x igual a esta
expresión entonces es el conjunto de
valores que podemos meter en la función
aquellos valores para los cuales está
esta expresión de aquí no queda
indefinida y la única forma en la cual
esta expresión puede quedar indefinida
es si dividimos entre 0 es decir cuando
6 - x es igual a 0 vamos a ver cuándo
sucede eso si 6x menos x es igual a 0
entonces sumando x de ambos lados
tenemos que 6 es igual a equis y por lo
tanto el dominio de esta función o bien
el dominio para esta expresión racional
son todos los reales excepto seis voy a
escribirlo por acá tenemos que el
dominio
es igual a todos los números reales
estas llaves a ver ahí está es todos los
números reales todos los números
números reales
reales excepto 6 excepto
excepto 6 muy bien entonces eso de ahí
es el dominio porque si ponemos 6
entonces aquí nos quedaría 6 menos x en
el denominador y entonces estaríamos
dividiendo entre 0 lo cual no se vale
bueno ya tenemos el dominio ahora vamos
a simplificar la expresión déjame volver
a copiar la de este lado la voy a poner
como x al cuadrado menos 36 dividido
entre 6 menos x y aquí seguramente ya
identificaste este tipo de binomio
especial que es de la forma cuadrada
menos b cuadrada a cuadrada menos b
cuadrada y ya sabemos cómo factorizar
este tipo de expresiones es una
diferencia de cuadrados de modo que es a
b x a menos b por a menos b y aquí es
igual a x b es igual a 6
entonces reescribiendo esta expresión
utilizando esta identidad nos queda x +
6 lo voy a poner así x
6 x x 6 x x menos 6 muy bien y eso lo
tenemos que dividir
entre 6 - x y observa que este término y
este término se parecen mucho sólo que
aquí es x 6 y aquí es 6 - x pero de
hecho uno es el negativo del otro lo
podemos verificar multiplicando por
menos uno por ejemplo si aquí multiplicó
por menos uno y vuelvo a multiplicar por
menos uno entonces el numerador lo
multiplique por uno y no he cambiado
nada y ahora puedo distribuir este menos
uno en esta expresión y me quedaría lo
siguiente voy a poner este el x6 que
tenemos por acá entonces sería x + 6 x y
ahora distribuyó este menos uno menos
uno por x es menos x menos 1 por menos
666 y todavía nos queda un menos uno por
acá déjame ponerlo al principio de la
expresión entonces quedaría esto y
todavía tenemos que dividir entre 6 - x
6 - x pero observa que está también en 6
- x
6 - x simplemente cambiamos el orden de
los sumandos así que
este término se puede cancelar con este
término y así la simplificación nos
queda menos 1 x x + 6 o si quieres
puedes distribuir el menos 1
nos quedaría menos x menos 6 y listo
esto sería la simplificación ahora no
tienes por qué andar multiplicando por
menos uno a cada rato en realidad esto
que hicimos acá es algo mucho más
sencillo simplemente si en algún momento
tenemos una expresión del estilo a menos
b / b menos a esto es igual a menos 1 es
igual a menos 1 y se justifica como lo
hicimos acá o bien dando dándonos cuenta
que a menos b simplemente es menos b
menos a son negativos entre sí bueno con
esto terminamos el ejercicio